We've now described what we call
the average velocity for a time
interval between when the
runner started at time t
to a later time
at t plus delta t.
And we described
that as the component
of the displacement vector
divided by the time interval
times a unit vector, i hat.
Now what we'd like to ask
is a separate question.
So our question
now is, what do we
mean by the velocity at
some specific time, T1?
Now in order to understand
that, let's just
make a plot of the
position function.
So remember we called the
component of the position
function x of t.
So we're going to plot the
component of the position
function with respect to time.
Now let's just say
that the runner started
at the origin of time equal 0.
So I can make some type of
arbitrary plot of that position
function.
And let's indicate in
particular, the time T1.
So what this
represents is x of T1.
And so first I'd like to
consider the interval T1
and T1 plus some
later time, delta T.
So let's make this
T1 plus delta t.
This is the time
delta t and up here
we have our position
function at T1 plus delta T.
Then for this time interval,
the average velocity,
so for this particular
time interval,
the average represents
delta x over delta t.
So it's just rise over run.
It's just the slope
of this straight line.
So for this particular
interval, the average
is the slope of the line
shown here on the figure.
Now this is just
an average velocity
and now what we would
like to do is shrink down
our interval delta T. So now
let's make another case where
we shrink delta t and
let's again calculate
the average velocity.
So for instance, suppose
we have a smaller delta t
and we draw that line.
Then our average velocity
represents that slope.
And again, we keep
on taking a limit.
So now we have another slope so
we have one slope, two slopes,
and now we shrink
again to a new delta t
and you can see that
the slope is changing.
And if we consider
the limit as delta t
goes to 0 of this
sequence of slopes,
then what are we getting,
you can see graphically,
that eventually we will
get to a line which
is the slope of the
tangent line at time T1.
And so in this
particular case, what
we mean by the instantaneous
velocity, v at time T1,
is the limit as delta
x goes to 0 i hat here
where we're taking,
this is the limit,
delta t goes to 0 x at
T1 plus delta t minus x1
of t divided by delta t and the
whole thing is a vector, i hat.
So what a limit is, is
a sequence of numbers.
So we take a fixed delta
t, we calculate the slope.
We take a smaller delta
t, calculate the slope.
And each time we do that,
the slopes represent
a sequence of numbers and
the limit of that sequence
you can see graphically,
is the slope
of the tangent line at time t 1.
And so what we say is, v of T1
is the instantaneous velocity
at time t equals t1.
And that's how we describe
instantaneous velocity
at some specific time.
If we were now being a
little bit more general,
we could just say
that v at any time t
is the limit delta
t goes to 0 delta
x over delta t ball
direction i hat,
and the only thing here is
we're no longer considering
T1 but an arbitrary time t.
This quantity, the limit, is
awkward to write every time.
It has a name.
And that's precisely what
we call the derivative
of the position function.
So our instantaneous velocity
is the time derivative
of the position function
at any instant in time.